on a clear road i crashed a car into a
ditch is what the prime minister has
said how damaging is this whole business
for you i think what the public expects
us to fix the problem what the pm has
said is that yes there's been a mistake
made
we regret that but now we're fixing it
and last night we voted in the house of
commons on a government
resolution which does two things one it
stops people acting as paid lobbyists or
consultants in relation to political
work that's critically important for
public confidence secondly in terms of
the broader question we've asked the
committee on standards to work up the
detail but around the principle that
your overriding priority must be serving
your constituents and therefore there
must be limits on external interests the
committee on standards will work that up
by january so it's not something that's
being put into the long grass so we're
tackling and fixing the problem at hand
okay um 297 to nil is how that went
through that vote yesterday where was
everybody else
the most important thing is it went
through overwhelmingly so um we can now
deal with the problem but a lot of tory
back benches are showing their true
feelings by not turning up to vote i
think there's probably other people that
uh thought that actually these were
common sense proposals very happy for
them to go through uh it was a late uh
late-ish vote um
i think it was around seven o'clock bit
later than that but look i can't account
for uh every member of parliament on on
either side i was there i voted i wanted
to vote because i think it's important
you accept though that there is unrest
amongst the party i mean the prime
minister went to meet a series of mps
last night as he walked into the room it
was apparently um completely silent
you'll always hear one or other
disgruntled individual anonymously in
the media on whichever side of a debate
my sense is overwhelmingly
mps wants us to fix the problem we've
done that move on to start talking about
the things that voters really care about
like the transport the infrastructure
the rail announcement we've made today
i'm very happy to answer the questions
but actually if you are talk to mps let
alone voters they want us focused on
their issues the quality of life issues
that matter to them they want this
resolved we've resolved it we're now
talking about rail today uh i'll come on
to that industry no sure i'm just saying
if if my the feedback mps give me is
they want the government same as our
constituents on the job of fixing the
problems that matter them in their daily
lives so there's no unrest at all as far
as the prime minister is concerned all
the backbenchers are completely happy
with him i'm not sure i put it quite in
that idyllic way how would you put it
i'd say look there's always uh debate uh
amongst mps but the most important thing
and the overwhelming response i've seen
is we're fixing the problem that's a
positive step forward we can get on with
the business uh and the job of bouncing
back from this recovery stronger cleaner
uh and dealing with things like
connectivity for northern cities cost of
living and all those other issues that
our voters care about okay let's talk
about what's happening with hs2 should
with the eastern leg of hst the prime
minister's written in the yorkshire post
basically saying that it's not going to
go ahead i mean why not but look first
of all the details of the different legs
will be announced later on today in the
house of commons i think that's the
right thing to do given the commercial
sensitivity i can tell you though 96
billion pounds going into infrastructure
rail infrastructure to link uh the rest
of the country with the midlands and the
north and critically the configuration
of the projects will mean we can deliver
those uh rail links much quicker and
they will focus not just on linking the
south london with the midlands and the
north but also the interconnectivity
between those regions when you talk to
small and medium-sized businesses in
those regions that is critical for them
because a lot of their market thrives
and the opportunities are about that
regional interconnectivity and that's
what 96 billion pounds of investment is
going to deliver 56 billion which is
already promised as part of hs2 we were
speaking to the chap earlier who was
responsible for the eastern leg
previously he says that the government
should think again it's absolutely the
wrong thing to do well as i've explained
the rationale for what we're doing it's
about speed of delivery it's about the
interconnectivity not just between the
south london the midlands and the north
but between the towns and the cities of
the north i'm not going to as i said for
commercial sensitivity reasons comment
on individual legs we will hear of the
hs2 route we'll hear the full detail uh
later in the house of commerce okay if
it's all about connectivity in the
region why not do the same on the
western leg of the hs2 line well i think
we're looking at the uh where you get
best value for taxpayers money where the
infrastructure will deliver the best
yield economically in terms of growth
and for the businesses that are already
there who've got the scope for expansion
and for for growing particularly you
think about small or medium-sized
businesses that can scale up what really
will matter to them what will really add
value to them and i know that the
transport secretary and the chancellor
have been very focused on delivering the
best bang for the buck for those
businesses and for the regional economy
uh in the north in the midlands and
that's where it's focused is it not
deputy prime minister the fact that the
metro mayors on the west of the country
are more vocal and as a result you
thought okay let's just keep that one
and forget about that
no but what we do want is uh active and
strong leadership from the metro mayors
from the local authorities who working
as a team
with central government and the
communities they serve can get the best
value economic value value for taxpayers
money out of these projects and of
course we do consult with local leaders
around the country that's that's that's
right that's what local democracy is all
about what about the northern powerhouse
rail line that goes um across the
pennines why why are you scrapping that
it was in the manifesto well look uh in
terms of the detail of individual legs
as i said uh that will all be announced
in the house of commons it's right to do
that you've been talking about sleeves
we want to respect the prime minister
wrote in the yorkshire post well we want
to respect in terms of beyond what
what's already been said we want to
respect the rules on commercial
sensitivity but what i can tell you in
terms of interconnectivity which is the
underlying point this is the 96 billion
is going to be absolutely focused not
just on the national links but the
regional links the interconnectivity
where it adds the most value so given
that you did it was um a promise in the
manifesto that there would be a cross
pennine link that will continue you'll
need to wait as uh i said earlier for
the full details uh of the projects and
the links and the regional links and the
limbs of hs2 and the other projects uh a
little longer but it will be out today
in the house of commons you're not gonna
have to wait long yeah what about the
people in bradford it's the seventh
biggest city um in the country it's the
only city the big city that isn't on a
main uh rail line and we were speaking
to somebody from bradford earlier they
say it's quicker it was quicker by steam
train than it is now right um
again we're very focused on bradford
they uh
a very important part of the country but
the specific projects the specific limbs
i've got to allow um the the prime
minister and the transport secretary to
set out the detail of that as a in the
way i described yeah the concern is that
uh leveling up is just a catchy phrase
and actually when it comes to it that
this conservative party this government
is not leveling up by any measure 96
billion pounds
50 odd billion that's already been
promised well sure but we're delivering
the projects we're setting out with a uh
as expedited a time frame as we can i
don't think anyone can reasonably uh say
that 96 billion pounds isn't a what
about people
on the main rail line i don't think
there has ever been a rail investment
project
on the scale of what this government is
doing i think anyone that is i mean you
people can quibble about individual
lines of course
and that's the scrutiny there's always
more demand than there is
supply with these things but but 96
billion pounds it's a step change it
will deliver the leveling up and by the
way that's good for the whole country
i'll be good for the midlands will be
good for the north more uh jobs uh more
tax revenue coming out of those uh polls
of economic activity be good for the
rest of the country to have a more
balanced economy it's good for
constituencies like mine because it'll
mean less pressure on housing
more tax revenue generated more broadly
i think it's good for the whole country
let's talk about migrants should we i'm
reading in the times this morning that
apparently we're going to gather them up
put them on planes
and send them to albania what a great
idea obviously not
well look we've seen
19 000
crossings stopped this year alone 65
convictions secured the criminal the
predatory criminal gangs that thrive on
this miserable trade and the home
secretary has been engaged with her
opposite number in france
this week their determination is to
eliminate all of these illegal crossings
i think it's right there's practice
around the world uh in relation to this
to look at least the possibilities of
international partnerships for
international processing of some of
these claims they're not going to
albania though aren't they come on but
that's one country but we've i mean as
foreign secretary we are willing uh to
look with partners at whether it's
possible to do this uh international
processing the point is as well as uh
focusing on uh regional processing which
is probably the most the best way the
optimum way to dealing with refugees at
close to source as possible better for
them but also we want to look with
international partners at how we reduce
the pull factor so that is the
incentives for the criminal gangs to try
and bring people from these war-torn
zones or these poorer parts of the world
to the uk we must reduce the pull factor
we'll look at all of the legitimate
means of doing that and we'll do so with
our with our partners and allies i think
i'm right in saying that only five
people have been uh sent back home
having come to the uk um illegally this
year the um home secretary who you
quoted there on a plane said the system
is broken
you guys have been in power for 11 years
well look and we've taken steps but the
demand and the pressures have increased
the two things that we're doing we uh
pretty patella is looking at this item
system she's got a plan to fix it we've
got a borders bill uh that is going to
be going through parliament i'm also
looking at the related underlying issues
around human rights we're going to be
putting forward proposals for
consultation in relation to that and we
know we've got a big problem
particularly foreign national offenders
and that is separate i don't want to
conflate the issue of
asylum with that but we know we have a
problem with returning people to
countries because of the expansion of
human rights so we will deal with both
of those issues the immigration and
border system but also the underlying
human rights framework but it was
incorrect wasn't it to suggest that um
all asylum seekers or the inference was
that asylum seekers are potential
terrorists that's what basically the
home secretary was saying yesterday i
don't think that's what she was saying i
certainly wouldn't say it my father was
a refugee to this country uh pretty
patel knows very well from coming from
her family came from uh
uh uganda indian ugandans uh that came
during the time of uh idiom and we know
we know exactly what it is like to flee
persecution but i think absolutely it's
right also to say we want a system that
is uh fair but also firm and rigorous
because that is the way you sustain
public confidence in the asylum and the
immigration system more broadly talk to
me about what's happening on the poland
belarus border given that you were
previously um foreign secretary of
course um i believe ten british soldiers
military engineers are on the border
effectively doing a recce there we've
seen what's happening to some of the
people that are gathered there they're
in freezing conditions people have died
what should we be doing
well first of all it is absolutely
despicable that belarus and there is now
increasingly uh
ever increasing evidence that they're
doing it in coups with russia which uh i
i've been saying for a long time
russia's questions to answer are trying
to use uh the the flux of refugees and
and economic migrants that are coming uh
uh through from the mediterranean indeed
north africa uh and the middle east and
trying to use that as pressure on the
european union and europe as a whole we
think that that is totally outrageous
and that's something where we would
stand in solidarity with poland and our
other european partners in resisting and
that is utterly unacceptable it's in
violation of all the principles and
norms of international law and yet a
further demonstration of the outrageous
behavior of the lukashenko regime we
have also already as you'll know that
sanctions on the lukashenko regime i did
it as foreign secretary uh the foreign
secretary liz truss has talked about
what further actions will take but
standing up in solidarity with our
european partners particularly poland
and others who are on the front line of
that i think it's critically important
just before i let you go at least half
of our audience this morning from today
until the end of the year will be
working for nothing because of the equal
because of where we are with equal pay
women do not get paid the same as men
that figure is getting worse rather than
better it's been illegal since 1975 to
pay women less than men what we going to
do about it well look uh if there's any
individual cases they should be dealt
with robustly by an employment tribunal
overall the gender pay gap has been
falling we know it's
bigger this year than it was last year
well i we're over um 11.6 percent since
2010 it is certainly reduced and but
it's going in the wrong direction look
at that then we need to solve that and
uh you know do that where we need to
look at the factors underpinning it
certainly if it is i mean there are
trends and ebbs and flows in the
workforce the pandemic would have
affected that um we know particularly
women are on
uh part-time hours will be affected by
things like that but look fundamentally
take another 170 years for women
apparently as we are at the moment to
get the same pay as men well we've done
a whole range of things uh in relation
to more flexible hours in relation to
the toughening up the rules uh why is it
not working then well we we i think i
think we have made substantial progress
but if there's data which shows we need
to do more that's exactly what we'll
look at good to talk to you thank you
very much